snuko meine lieben freunde ich darf euch
heute recht herzlich willkommen heißen
zu einer neuen nicht lachen challenge
heute allerdings ohne sandra weil
[Gelächter]
ich will mich heute wirklich
zusammenreißen nicht zu lachen
heute im studio caren miosga nahm vor
song kann mir ausgehalten
selbst angespuckt alt aber ich nach oben
gesprungen tat der mitmenschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend eines
haustieres zu denken immer holen
[Musik]
was ich lasse es mir gut gehen immer
nach dem motto lieber barfuß zum schluss
heißt mit dem mercedes uns bewogen
[Musik]
schlimmste moment
ich gestern in
singapur ein
musik geht an airports aus
aber weshalb nur der linke
rechts lief schön weiter
schwimmen mit geräuschunterdrückung auch
noch mit drin richtig geil 7 auf die
fresse geflogen weil ich das mit dem
schwergewicht sinn nicht wäre
[Musik]
ich lache nur bei seien schwachsinn
alter ich brauch ein anderes video etwas
[Applaus]
auszustrahlen austria
sind für mehr holen sydney rpo
[Musik]
ich verstehe auch nicht warum heißes
austria in österreich
oder keine ahnung war es also 99 prozent
von euch wissen wirklich bauen
pauli vor allem erwarte jetzt ein online
seminar wird hat er noch whatsapp
aufrichtigen welche nachrichten rein
da sehe ich mich auch irgendwann mal
sonne mit irgendwas im hintergrund
geschrieben hat keine ahnung was das
hier irgendwas noch einen drauf und hier
steht auch die in welche grundrisse von
welchen sachen die keinen sinn ergeben
dass das man in zukunft
[Musik]
diese videos ist immer gleich man es ist
auch nicht vergänglich sein irgendwann
bock das einfach nicht mehr
[Musik]
meine ganz for you page of tech talk ist
voll mit irgendwelchen schnee der umfeld
oder eins der offenen see geknallt wird
oder so kommt eigentlich aus deutschland
wo ist eine große stadt großstadt
in deutschland
also in europa bestimmen
[Musik]
einfach mal nicht wissen wo man wohnt
irgendwo deutschland europa oder so
wahrscheinlich rom hat die form der
badewanne ein in form der eiche
[Musik]
hat niemand was geht und ich lade schon
von der größe passt auf jeden fall
[Musik]
wie viel co2 könnte man einsparen wenn
karl lauterbach nicht dreimal die woche
zu markus lanz pendeln ich glaube der
macht das aber relativ co2 schwung
kommen die frage war witzig aber seine
antwort schon wieder einer der gp so auf
den keks
da habe ich
würde
[Musik]
ja wort von
über 80 also vier fünftel der komplett
welt in den nächsten fünf jahren sterben
weil snowboards sind okay alles klar die
zwischen hase lang ich meine nase macht
der pinner für eine ansage du hast keine
henseler von bülows gebe ich im keller
versteckt nach schönbüel
so sehr am ihrer steilheit ist erst ab
13 oder das sind wir ja beide schon ja
dann haben wir da auch kein problem aber
ich fand gestern 6
denn ich finde ich 13 geworden wie für
immer
ich verstehe nicht wieso kleine kinder
immer so grinsen können
nein
dann überlegt und support für die
variante liebe liebe liebe entschieden
[Musik]
muss man wirklich lange
überlegen ist dass hamburg sich hier
platz eins
ist der ökonom studio sollen richtig
guter podcast sein spotify laut und
lästig und du
du bist hat 1
ich meine sie ab jetzt die diese woche
noch aber letzte woche auf jeden fall
war ich im amateurbereich platz eins
weltweit
das erklärt natürlich einiges weißt du
noch hier
in spanien
will story ganz frage aber ich verstehe
so was nicht
warum flex man so mit geld also ja wenn
du dir davon was schönes kaufst
irgendwie nur haut ohne wohnung kleine
ahnung was auch immer man sich davon
kaufen möchte aber mit dem geld an sich
zu flexen hey das war einfach nur
kitschig springen
[Musik]
also wenn man bei einem cut server egal
wieder die haare stadt ja doch gut
unternehmen die man so den spiegel und
zeigen dann so von hinten und dann
musste ich etwas anderes sagen
willst du dich mein und wie ich der
einzige der immer so fragt was sage ich
jetzt sage ich jetzt ja auch gut oder
schlecht da der übergang auch gut sind
keine ahnung
das war ja
das stand besonders aber
er ist das längst anzuordnen die stimme
ob das jetzt irgendwie vielleicht seine
freundin ist oder auch irgendwo 12
jähriger cousin mit piepsstimme alexa
spiel musik für kinder zwischen sechs
und neun
[Musik]
ich dachte es kommt jetzt irgendwie
diese spinne raus gesprungen oder so
aber das ist auch das einzige was es
gibt diese komischen weißem plastik
weich platz drei jungs heute hat nichts
mit fussball er ich muss auch meine
kleine schwester aufpassen er tot dann
geschafft damit tim alleine provieh
alister den schwestern im jedoch ein
mann mit
hut dienstag
wie findest du eigentlich alles
was ein kleiner hit ich habe nichts
gemacht aber ich habe mich schon
geschossen
die meisten posträuber gehalten ja auf
jeden fall ich habe mich mal geschossen
habe nichts gemacht kommt von ich gesagt
ich mache meine finger
also ich verstehe gar nichts
der titel macht einfach sinn frankfurt
hat einfach eine eigene sprache ist
frankfurt tätig so gottlos asozial
brauchen ja ein kopf heute ist eine
sache im kopf wollte heute morgen
[Musik]
im alter ist das ekelhaft das ist
mindestens genauso eklat viele leute die
nachts auf summen ledersofa schlafen
da schließen wir uns auf die klippen
sofort deinem rücken bro war gestern die
party ohne ende
da bin ich jetzt auch einfach raus was
ist denn das für ein typ wenn ihr
allerdings bock auf weitere nicht lachen
challenges hauptanlass kann einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da abonniert
main kanal und klick auf die glocke
damit ihr weitere videos nicht verpassen
werden wenn ihr auch möchte dass sarah
dem nächsten video mit dabei sein
schreibt jedoch gerne auf instagram sie
heißt ein laser luca könnte da auch gern
mal folgen